la coop des masses que m'a offert une
seconde chance on savait qui j'étais ici
mais on n'a pas jugé pour la personne
que j'ai fait mais pour l' envie de
travailler voilà
[Musique]
et
si je suis conducteur de ligne donc
c'est moi qui fais en sorte qu'ils
m'empêchent de matières premières sur
les machines
voilà je fais des réglages sur la
machine je viens mais vu la qualité des
masques
[Musique]
j'ai postulé j'ai postulé et donc le
plusieurs entreprises me refuser parce
que je m'appelais tristan lozach et
parce que j'avais été médiatisé le
j'aurais aimé porter plainte contre les
entreprises qui ont fait de la
discrimination ça c'est clair mais ya
pas de preuve l'exemple dans une
entreprise la très loin d'ici
au bout d'une semaine il me dit de
combat mais sur les actes qui ont trahi
redoublé très bien très bon travail et
finalement on dit mise plus tard il est
revenu me voir en disant ah mais vous
êtes triste en aux actes le gilet jaune
et j'ai dit bah oui oui il est là il m'a
répondu dehors sauf que j'avais pas
d'enregistrement n'y avait pas de vidéo
il n'y avait pas de salariés autour
[Musique]
en
tout j'ai eu 3000 euros n'ont jamais
payé déjà une partie mais il me reste
cinq cents et quelques euros damende en
jours-amende et donc c'est vrai que si
je devais paye pas ça se transforme donc
en peine de prison ferme
[Musique]
la colère non elle n'est pas redescendu
bien au contraire ça s'empire et on
n'est pas à l'abri un jour d'une voilà
du d'un retour du mouvement des gels et
jaune à mon avis dans les mois qui
viennent
[Musique]